et
pour les surfeurs la seule dimension
vivable et celle du globe seules
frontières admise celle des vagues ces
derniers investi dans la panoplie mon
oeil pour la couleur du corps ont
oxygéné pour ça de la chevelure lexique
anglo français pour la conversation et
pour essayer de décrypter surfer ou
surfing magazine et puis le sorte la
chemise et les chaussures il arrive sur
la plage aux heures de pointe gare sa
voiture face à la mer et scrute le
rivage en décrétant que de toute façon
aujourd'hui n'est pas en forme ou que
les vagues sont trop petites pour qu'ils
consentent à mouiller sa planche on
utilise un peu plus téméraires y va
quand même à l'eau et sa copine les yeux
rivés sur la ligne bleue des vagues doit
pouvoir l'assurer que son code bac était
extraordinaire et c'est roller coaster
incomparable de toute façon ils
cherchent à établir des performances
plus important pour lui c'est d'assurer
son look auprès des copains enfin bien
évidemment c'est portrait ne concerne
pas les vrais sportifs ceux qui sont à
lacanau et qui surf même en hiver si les
vagues sont bonnes d'ailleurs je suis
certaine qu'ils n'ont pas pu se
reconnaître dans ces clichés rapide
ouais